mark on the movie a director has to know
a thousand different jobs whether it be
writing story lighting sound makeup
working with actors editing so on and so
forth when it comes down to it what do
you think is the most important job of a
director okay the most important job to
me is really simple if you think about
it first of all the director of a film
is a storyteller thank everybody who is
working with is there to help tell one
story so the directors primary job is to
be the shepherd of that story take care
of the story and tell the story as
clearly as honestly and as authentically
as possible
I say story not the script the script
which we can talk about later is a step
towards getting the story told in terms
of your question what you're asking
about in terms of the story being told
at the center of the story the most
important part of the story are the
characters it's the characters who tell
the story not the cinematography not the
production design not all those other
elements all those other elements are a
support system to the story so the
director needs to be focusing on the
story and then on the characters and the
strength of the performances the
authenticity of the performances the
clarity of characters the clarity of
relationships the clarity of the journey
of each character is really crucial in
order to tell the story well that's the
primary focus of a director and if a
director can't do that or loses sight of
that the story is going to start to
wobble and we've seen that a lot stories
which wobble because simply because of
performance even though a lot of the
other elements may be brilliant like CGI
and special effects and all that all
that stuff is beautiful it's wonderful
but it's not the story is the story
wobbling because the actors are wrong
for the part when you say shepherding
the story where would that get lost
where would the director in the course
of let's say a 14-hour day
on set working with actors lose that can
you give some examples of what things
could happen or how things could have a
you brought up two things what could
happen in a 14 hour day and then you
brought up a casting question so there
are two questions
you know if the actor is right I'm going
to go back to the casting first first of
all the casting which is really crucial
and very often we've all seen films
where we feel the casting although
understandable is not right doesn't feel
like that actor is bringing me closer to
the character and many times that actor
is a star or whatever so you can
understand why so the casting is really
important that we the audience the goal
is that we the audience lose sight of
the actor and are only watching the
character and many times the actor even
the power of the actor or the the career
of the actor or a lot of other things
can get in the way of us connecting with
the character one more thing in casting
you can cast someone who can't seem to
get to the character just nothing to do
with star power
so casting is really important to find
someone who can actually access that
character know in a 14 hour day is that
saying a 14 hour day only shooting a
couple of scenes or one scene or
whatever we're doing in that day you ask
how the director can lose sight of the
shepherding of the story very easily
very easily and I can tell you as a
director and having directed a lot of
films and having worked on a lot of
films you can see it happen
it's what a friend of mine mark Riedel
who I worked with a lot called the big
machine the big machine is the
filmmaking process cameras lights crew
all of its huge you've been on a set you
know what it's like it's enormous and
the director is sort of the leader the
guy that everybody's looking to and what
can happen is the director gets
distracted by all the challenges
everything he has to do I'm not saying
it doesn't have to do that it has to do
a lot that and can lose sight of what is
most important you're shooting that
close-up of that actor
at that moment what's the most important
the lighting no the background no the
special effects no what's most important
is that performance I heard once on a
set a director after they had shot a
moment turn to the script supervisor and
say did she say all the words the script
supervisor says yes and says okay good
moving on his his criteria was did she
say all the words not was that the
performance we need in other words can
the director keep their focus on the
performance because when it comes down
to the film and we see it on the screen
what do we see the performance the big
thing that mark Riedel told me about is
you can be on the set and watching oh
that was great
that was wonderful you can even be in
dailies and watch it later go great
wonderful you're gonna see at home later
and go huh what happened to great and
wonderful the machine is taken away a
lot of directors get their energy from
the big machine from the fact that
there's a crew when there are lights and
energy everybody goes quiet everybody's
listening Wow
there it get excited by the fact that
they are shooting a film and that
excitement will go away and then you
look at the shot and go huh I thought it
was great when we did it what happened
what happened was there's an energy
around you which is now gone so a
director's job is can you shut down the
big machine can you focus your attention
onto just what that actress is doing
what she's giving to you can you see
only that now that's really hard and one
other aspect of this assuming that
you've been working with this actress a
lot and you've rehearsed and you've
discussed this intention so you know
what you're going for and you know what
she's going for can you watch her in
that moment not only shut down the big
machine but can you watch her in that
moment as if you've never seen her
before and you seen what she's doing for
the first
time that's hard it's the hardest thing
a director has to do